et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec jean-paul chang économiste et
spécialiste de la chine mon jour
monsieur jean paul chang merci d'être en
direct avec nous alors une montée de
tension qui intervient dans un contexte
de dégradation entre les relations
bilatérales sino américaines la chine
qui a tout de suite donc répliquer à ces
représailles mais qui pékin vis il quand
il parle de responsables américains qui
se sont mal comportés en lien avec le
tibet justement provenant des
parlementaires américains qui ont fait
passer des lois en janvier sur le tibet
en janvier de cette année effectivement
le congrès a passé une loi centré sur la
liberté religieuse au tibet et menaçant
de sanctions les officiels chinois qui
as they have i regrets éventuellement
dans le processus de la réalisation du
dalaï lama de donc de dire que
effectivement que si le web chinois au
lycée chine interviennent dans le
processus du choix du successeur d'aller
là bas ils font l'objet de sanctions
alors maintenant les américains
remettent une couche si j'ose dire
après les affaires de hong kong toute
façon faut pas oublier que tibet fait
partie de la boîte à outils mais que les
américains ont développé depuis quelques
années à savoir le tibet le xinjiang
ouïgours quoi pour le think-tank ongles
qui a été rajouté laganière et taiwan
galanta lui qui est un problème depuis
toujours donc pas uniquement aux sommes
nés à réactiver ces thèmes avec du côté
chinois une crainte bien entendu que en
réactivant une offensive sur le tibet
c'est des signaux qui seraient renvoyés
à des sécessionnistes et qui viendrait
compromettre éventuellement la stabilité
et la tranquillité dans la région du
tibet donc c'est donc ils ont répondu
immédiatement la menace et la
traditionnelle à savoir c'est la semaine
des finances si vous avez un chine
mais quel nom il va faire le blanc il
est vrai que les américains ont passé
loi sur loi concernant des territoires
qui sont entièrement contrôlée par pékin
mais cela est probablement destinée à
susciter une campagne d'opinion
internationale autour de ce thème parce
que sur le terrain même je ne pense pas
que ça a un effet quelconque
voilà ce qui est un peu un peu ne plus
conjoncturelle je dirais c'est que le
dallai lama est quand même à g et il
l'est il ya commence à parler de sa
succession en évoquant la possibilité de
choisir démocratiquement un successeur
lui or ça ça serait évidemment une
première dans l'histoire que pékin
[Musique]
légitime impeccable jusque il faut
suivre la voie traditionnelle du choix
du successeur mais uniquement après la
mort des deux lamas donc ellis manquant
que les américains visant est ce que
vous voulez précipité la mort du dalaï
lama
voilà donc erroné on est dans des des
échanges entre berger à la bergère
et tout ça autour de deux grands pays
des logiques avec ses précise sur le
tibet un accent plus mis autour du thème
la chine répriment la liberté religieuse
ne respectent pas leur légitimité
etc voilà justement on en est où
exactement
dans la relation les relations entre
entre le tibet lâché en fait bon il faut
bien voir qu'il ya quand même les
changements il ya eu des émeutes en mars
2008 si je me souviens c'était l'époque
des jeux olympiques c'est effectivement
des indépendantistes ou nécessité
latinistes type d'état avait profité
donc de la lumière du jour la pique à
l'époque pour se signaler à l'opinion
nationale donc mais depuis ça c'est
quand même beaucoup calmé il ya eu des
transformations économiques et
sociologiques très très importante au
tibet jeunes générations de tibétains
je vais dire be un environnement
totalement différent
la chine a construit des chemins de fer
qui me ramène tout près maintenant de
l'aca vous avez des interconnexions
entre le tibet et le reste du pays des
échanges économiques qui sont quand même
très importante et donc l'ambiance n'est
plus du tout la même c'est à dire qu'en
fait le la nature du pouvoir temporel si
j'ose dire a changé au tibet donc ce
n'est pas ce n'est plus du tout le monde
que c'est la raison pour laquelle je
pense que même du côté du dalaï lama
ils ont conscience que c'est en train de
changer et que il ya toujours eu des
négociations avec pékin pour essayer de
trouver une solution mais bon et
uniquement celle utilisée par les
voitures mandé des trous des parties
tiers d'ailleurs par les états unis en
tout cas pour pour comme thème comme
comme levier idéologique contre la chine
mais sur place des choses ont quand même
beaucoup beaucoup changé voilà donc et
aussi un contentieux entre les
américains et les chinois c'est les
américains veulent absolument installer
un consulat alors que les chinois disent
écoutez pour installer un consulat aux
termes de la convention de vienne
il faut qu'il y ait une population en
prime des résidents américains nombreux
au tibet ou alors qui est né des
relations très développée avec ubs avec
les etats-unis ce qui n'est pas le cas
donc les macarons passer une loi aussi
depuis 2002 déjà vous dire que tant que
les américains ne peuvent pas ouvrir
conçu de là à massat et bien les chinois
ne pourront pas ouvrir de nouveaux
consulats aux états unis donc là en ce
moment on approche des élections
présidentielles américaines a plus le
thème les thèmes critiques contre la
chine sert de secondes mobilisateur pour
l'électorat trempe
plus on va assister à ce genre en
échange mais tout à fait je pense tout à
fait de manière réaliste je pense que
c'est pas ça qui va bouleverser la
situation au tibet merci beaucoup jean
paul chance d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle donc que vous êtes
économiste et spécialiste de la chine